(soothing music)
(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Deep in
the Himalayan Mountains,
about 80 miles outside of Katmandu,
the Bhujung Village takes part
in a death-defying tradition.
All in the name of honey.
- [Narrator] But procuring
this precious honey
takes more than just strength.
A team of honey hunters assembles
twice a year to prepare.
And Madan, he leads the pack.
(birds singing)
(chatting in foreign language)
- [Narrator] Today,
ancient customs are
still closely followed.
Before each hunt, Madan
must visit the village guru
to receive his blessing.
(chanting in foreign language)
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] One day, Madan
will fill the guru's shoes.
In the meantime, he leads
his team of honey hunters
into the jungle.
(energizing music)
The team braids and re-secures
their handmade rope ladders.
Then, they venture to the cliffside
where the beehives are hiding.
The team creates smoke fires down below
to encourage the giant bees to scatter.
Madan lowers himself onto the rope,
dangling hundreds of feet from the ground.
- [Narrator] Despite
the incessant stinging
on his unprotected skin, he
calmly cuts away at the hive,
fulfilling his duty and
securing his liquid gold.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] The hives are
collected by the hunters
and packed up to bring back to the village
where their safe return is celebrated.
(low chime rings)